another finalist for this year's
National Book Award in nonfiction is
Kathy O'Neill she's the author of
weapons of mass destruction which
examines the many algorithms used by
organizations to determine approval or
denial of services loans and more
[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
coming out tonight my name is Davis and
I am part of the event staff at the
politics of Rose and it's our honor to
welcome you to hear Kathy O'Neill speak
about her new book weapons weapons of
mass destruction I'm really excited to
get into this conversation but I do have
a few housekeeping notes I want to let
you know before we get started if people
take this moment to style at your cell
phones or any noise making devices so we
don't have any interruptions algorithmic
or otherwise and also I just want to
mention that the formatted in this event
we're gonna have a new conversation
person for 20 to 30 minutes and then you
will have the opportunity to ask
questions and since we have c-span
recording the event tonight now we'd
really appreciate it if you'd raise your
hand when you have a question and I can
bring this this wireless mic around to
you so that we can have all of the
questions reported and everyone can hear
and participate in the conversation so
thank you very much for that we will be
doing a book signing after after the
event is over and that's going to be
right here with the tablecloths or the
white tape brought this she will be
there to sign books if you'd like to
purchase the book you can't pay for it
here but you can pay for it in the front
in the bookstore so if you you can
either head out after the event - okay
and come back to 20 copies by the
register or I get it signed here before
you go out I also just want to make a
mention that this is a politics impose
it does impose event it's great you can
order food and drinks throughout this is
a partnership that we have been
developing over the past year and a half
we're located here at WK also
fortunately Buffalo's location as well
as the Tacoma so if you pick up the
calendar you can find where these type
of this are happening throughout the
city so I you know I first learned what
an algorithm was when I learned how to
solve a Rubik's Cube in middle school
but I think that this world has gone way
beyond the simple challenge of a Rubik's
Cube algorithm we live in an age of the
algorithm increasingly the decisions
that affect our lives where we go to
school whether we get a car loan how
much we pay for health insurance are
being made not by humans but by
mathematical models in theory this
should lead to greater fairness everyone
is judged according to the same rules
and biases eliminated but as Cathy
O'Neill reveals in this urgent and
necessary book the opposite is true the
models being used today are opaque
unregulated and uncontestable even when
they're wrong most troubling they
reinforced these discrimination so
scientific American part Evelynn land
reviews O'Neill is an ideal person to
write this book she's an academic
mathematician turned Wall Street quant
turned data scientist who has been
involved in Occupy Wall Street and
recently started an algorithmic auditing
company she's one of the strongest
voices speaking out for limiting the
ways we allow algorithms to influence
our lives and against the notion that an
algorithm because it is implemented by
an Endon unemotional machine cannot
perpetuate clients or injustice
Kirkus Reviews says it's unusual and
unusually loosen and readable look at
the daunting outer those that govern so
many aspects of our lives
Kathy Lillard a PhD in math department
so postdoc at the MIT math department
and a professor at Barnard College she
switched over to the private sector
working as plot for the hedge fund de
Shaw and the purpose of metrics metrics
of a software company assessing the risk
for holdings of hedge funds and things
she left finance in 2011 and started
working as a data scientist in the New
York startup scene from doing data
science in 2013 and loss of lead program
and data journalism at Columbia and 2014
she's a weekly guest on a slate money
podcast and you may know her from her
blog math babe available be enjoyed in
conversation by denkova computer science
test and professor at the University of
Maryland so if you will please join me
in welcoming Kathy
[Applause]
so we're gonna like algorithm geek out
up here for y'all so maybe we can
actually jump right in and get some like
definitions and ideas out there and also
talk about one of the examples in your
book because we were chatting in the
back as you all came in and I was saying
you know one of the projects we've done
in my lab is to take all of your data
from Twitter or Facebook and use that to
predict your personality traits so how
many of you have done like a
myers-briggs like the INTJs sort of
personality test yeah so it turns out
that lots of businesses wants you to
take those and you don't need to take
them anymore because we have algorithms
that can just look at all the data you
leave behind and find them out
automatically and then potentially use
that in ways you may like or may not
right the youngest thing I wouldn't like
that yeah so we're going to talk about
what a weapon of mass destruction is in
a minute but like we thought we might
start with an example just and then we
can sort of like draw out its the
characteristics that make it a weapon of
mass destruction and by that I mean like
there's some algorithms that I care
about and some well most algorithms I
don't care about the ones that I care
about I think are potentially really
destructive I call them weapons of mass
destruction and they're characterized by
three characteristics but we're going to
start with an example okay to make it
real so the example if you don't mind me
starting there is so there's this guy
named Kyle beam he's like he was a
college student at near Atlanta and he
wanted to get a part-time job at
Kroger's grocery store and he had a
friend who worked at Kroger's and his
friend was leaving so his friend was
like I talked to my manager and you've
got my job you just have to fill out the
paperwork online and so he started to
fill out the paperwork and like 60% of
job applicants in this country he was
required to take a personality test
online before he got the interview
so if he fail the personality test which
he did then you wouldn't get to the
interview process and this is a standard
procedure for lots of minimum-wage jobs
especially so he so he failed it and he
he was lucky because most people don't
find out but they found that they just
never gonna call back for the interview
so he found out because even his Frank
told them that he got redlighted that's
what it's called and then he's unusual
in a second way which is that his father
is a lawyer you know most people
applying to minimum wage jobs don't have
fathers that are powerful lawyer or so
he talked to his father and his father
asked him like what what kind of
questions were there on this test
because like you're very very qualified
to get a job as a grocery bagger at a
grocery store maybe he was going to a
competitive college he got me straight
A's in high school like what's the
problem and he said well dad the
questions were a lot like the ones I got
at the hospital when I was being treated
for bipolar disorder the five-factor
model which is a mental health
assessment I'd do you know about it
that's right so the five factor model is
actually what we could predict so it
looks at things like are you need from
Burton or an extrovert but also things
like neuroticism which measures how
emotionally stable are you so if you get
really anxious or if you get
you would have a fine neuroticism score
I do or you know if you're super mellow
and nothing bothers you then you score
low on that and it's easy to find that
out through a test but it turns out
those signals also show up in all kinds
of other data we leave behind - oh my
god that's so frightening so what
happened was he talked to his father
like I'm so glad to me we're gonna talk
more about the fact that you don't even
have to take his test to infer this
about someone but essentially what
happened was his father who's a psychic
that's illegal you can't you can't as
part of a process of hiring someone you
can't make them take a health exam
including the mental health exam and
that's what that's that's the Americans
with Disability Act that's it's trying
to prevent this sort of creation of an
underclass of people with with
disabilities or mental health problems
so his father is suing on behalf a
class-action lawsuit on behalf of anyone
who ever took this test and I should add
by the way that Kyle went ahead and
tried to get a job at six other large
companies in the Atlanta area and he got
the same personality test for all of
them
so he was and he was regulated for all
of them so he was like systematically
prevented from getting a job in his in
his area so that's the first example I
wanted to talk about do you want
anything I want to see that really takes
us towards this definitional question
because this here we're talking about a
test but in fact a lot of these
kinds of insights about people come from
these models that are built on
algorithms in a whole bunch of data and
they work sort of opaquely and the fact
that they can harm people or have bias
even though on the surface it looks like
they don't have bias that's really the
nature of your weapons of mass
destruction concept right right maybe
you can define yeah so let me just go
ahead and define a weapon of mass
destruction it's an algorithm that has
three properties the first is that it's
widespread and impactful so it matters
like there's lots of algorithms out
there like the ones I build in my
basement because that's what I do I'm a
data scientist I build algorithms all
the time nobody cares about the ones
that build in my basement right they
start caring and they should start
caring when they affect a lot of people
in important ways and this is an example
because it was widely used
Cronos who built this algorithm was
actually located in Boston and sold it
to all sorts of people all sorts of
companies to use instead of their HR
people so it's widespread and impactful
the second is that it's secret so Kyle
did not understand how he was being
scored and most people who took this
personality test did not even understand
that they were being scored they just
knew that this was a coach they had to
jump through and finally its destructive
so he destroyed Kyle's chances of
getting a job but it's actually
destructive in this larger sense and
that's characteristic of all these
weapons of mass destruction these
terrible algorithms that they actually
create they sort of create and reinforce
a feedback loop which is destructive to
society as a whole and here the
destructive larger feedback loop is like
systematically refusing to employ people
with certain disorders and I think you
one of the examples that I like both mut
liked most in the book is when you open
to it which is actually a local
and it highlights the really secretive
black box nature of these algorithms and
including by the way as a computer
scientist some really crappy ways of
validating them and that was they're
using the DC school system for getting
teachers fired so maybe you can talk a
little about that yeah so a second
example so michelle array with school
chancellor for some time and she
instituted this policy whereby some
people would get fired if they had bad
teacher assessments and some people
would get bonuses that they got really
good teacher assessments now the
assessments are complicated but the very
short version is that most of the ways
that teachers are assessed is are like
are not very they don't have a lot of
spread so like most people get
acceptable or very good and the people
who really want to just discriminate
between bad teachers and good teachers
are frustrated with that they want they
wanted they want more spread in their
scoring systems they want like more
people who are terrible in a medium and
then good fare better and then very good
so they were frustrated by the fact that
very few of the ways that we could that
we now assess teachers have any kind of
spray which they think of as information
so they instituted this this assessment
this new kind of assessment called the
the growth score or the value-added
score of a teacher and i won't go into
it too technically but the the very
broad way of diffe thinking about this
is the idea is that the teacher the
teacher is on the hook for the
difference between what its what their
student her students should have gotten
versus what they actually got so there's
an underlying model that estimates what
each student in a class should get so if
you guys were all my class like and I'm
teaching you 5th grade okay you're all
5th graders right now each of you got at
the end of fourth grade you each got a
score for your standardized test right
let's say you got a 75 out of 100 then
you should be
you would be expected to get something
like a 75 B in the fifth grade the fifth
grade test right now let's say you
actually got an 80 then I will be given
credit for those five points that you
got more than you were expected okay
does that make sense now it's not as
clear how this expected score is
actually determined per student and it's
actually really complicated and it's a
source of uncertainty and there's also
another source of uncertainty which is
what you actually got at the end of
fifth grade or what will you'll actually
will get at the end of fifth grade
because after all like tests vary every
year and kids get different score
depending on whether it's the morning or
the afternoon or whether they had
breakfast before the test and that kind
of thing so there's like these two
sources of uncertainty and and the
teacher again to remind you the teachers
on the hook for the difference between
those two things
okay now actually if you think about
this this original expected score that
each of you got the difference between
the expected score and the actual score
is called the error term it's in
statistics so I've just it's also
sometimes called normal boys so the
teachers are being assessed based on
these error terms which is I'm if you're
not a statistician I don't want you to
be confused all I'm saying is that we
and statistics would call this stuff
essentially pretty meaningless and in
fact the way the teachers the scores
actually came out where it was almost
meaningless and I say that not because I
have like hard data on that because it's
actually a secret score the only way I
got my hands on any real data
besides story as I taught I talked to
the various teachers I talked to one
teacher who was who got a 6 out of 96
100 in 2010 and a 96 out of one hundred
and twenty eleven he was from New York
City and in in general we but in general
it's a secret system which I we can't
get our hands on so it's another source
of opacity so anyway going back to
Washington DC and Michelle Reed I
interviewed this woman named Sarah
wausaukee
who actually got fired because her
overall teacher assessments where it was
too low now again it wasn't entirely due
to this value at his score it was 50% of
it but the other 50% as I said was were
these things that don't have any spread
so the most of the information in her
score was actually this terrible
value-added score okay one more thing to
tell you about this sarah's score is
that a lot of she was a fifth grade
teacher a lot of her fourth graders had
gotten really good scores at the end of
4th grade right well the kids coming
into her class in fifth grade pick up
excellent 4th grade scores but they
couldn't read and they couldn't write
and so she was suspicious of their
really very good scores and in fact she
has every reason to believe that the
teachers of those kids cheated on their
tests at the end of the year in order to
get better value item model scores for
themselves because then their their kids
got better than expected so they got
good scores but they set her up to get
worse than expected does that make sense
so she's very good reason to believe
this there's all sorts of unusual
erasers I don't know if you guys
remember that scandal that happened in
this area but there are unusual erasers
which never really got systematically
investigated they got touched touched
basically so but in any case she got
fired from this test so I just let's go
back over the three characteristics of
the weapons of mass destruction it's
widespread okay value by the model
scores are being used in more than half
the states mostly in urban school
districts
it's secret so Sara didn't understand
her scourge and she was suspicious of it
again but she when she appealed it they
said you know no it's fair because it's
mathematical and finally it's
destructive not only not only did it
destroy Sara's life because he had she
got the fire I mean did a store I
actually should say she got rehired like
the following week in a sort of affluent
suburb where they don't use this scoring
system and that goes to the final thing
which is that it was destructive in a
larger sense because and that's what I
think you will be surprised if you know
about Michelle Rhee and why she was
brought in which is that there's a sort
of nationwide kind of war on teachers
going on which is the idea is find the
bad teachers get rid of them and then
we'll fix education and it's been like a
bunch of presidents who wanted to be the
president that fixed education we could
talk about whether that even makes sense
but in any case the idea was to get rid
of the bad teachers right and then the
larger destructive feedback loop
engendered by the value-added model is
that it hasn't gotten rid of bad
teachers it's been getting rid of good
teachers because good teachers they've
been quitting they've been retired early
and most of all they've been moving to
affluent suburbs that don't have this
scoring system and right now we have
like a nationwide shortage of teachers
so I would argue that this this this
regime of this okay algorithm value that
model has been very very bad and I think
it's something that's especially
insidious about this so you know we
talked about algorithms and they can
sound very kind of like techie and
foreign things that we don't interact
with but a lot of the the algorithms
that we're talking about here that we
both work on have tons of similarities
sometimes are identical underneath to
the algorithms like on Netflix that
recommend shows for you or an Amazon
recommend books for you to buy and if
you think about that we totally know how
to handle those right Amazon's like most
the time it's super boring and not
insightful right like you bought a
Stephen King book and it's like how
about these other Stephen King books and
it's like you're right but not helpful
right and sometimes it's totally wrong
and you just go like where did this come
from and then sometimes you get these
beautiful glimmers of insight right so I
bought this all be Survival Guide and
then it recommended i buy this hand axe
with like an 18 inch knife that pulls
out like i never would have thought of
that that was a great insight but you
know you don't just buy everything
amazon recommend you don't watch every
show that netflix says to watch but the
algorithms that you're talking about
people don't treat them as one point in
a human decision-making process they
treat them as like this Oracle of truth
even when they're poorly validated even
when the people using them don't
understand them and that makes them a
lot more destructive because you
override all of our great human
intuition with this little bit of math
great point and I would argue that it's
actually worse than what you just said
which is pretty good you know how like
you know how let me give you two
examples okay you know how like the
threat the Facebook trending story thing
has been [ __ ] up lately you could see
these weird fake stories well guess what
we noticed them right and we give
feedback to Facebook saying that's not a
real story right that's that's something
that doesn't happen for the teacher
value-added model there was no ground
truth for those teachers there was no
secondary assessment of those teachers
to compare their scores to they were
just told this is your score the guy who
has got a six out of a hundred was
shamed the decks fear he got a 96 out of
100 and he was like what does that mean
I went from being a terrible teacher to
a great teacher like there is no ground
truth to compare it to there's no
feedback mechanism teacher so teachers
can't say actually yo I'm actually a
really good teacher
so please update your model that's
that would be the equivalent of like uh
say hey Netflix I don't want to see that
movie because it's awful please don't
show that you'd have a button right like
don't recommend me anything like this
ever again right we have a way to tell
Netflix it's messing up teachers did not
have access to that way so your parents
or administrators who kind of knew
they'd be good right they couldn't go in
and override exactly exactly so but
you're right I think the thing that
other thing that you I want to agree
with is that people really did they
really did just trust these scores
because they were mathematical actually
the way I came about across this
algorithm is that my friend is a
principal in Brooklyn of a high school
in New York City and she started
complaining to me about these her
teachers getting scored and I just said
well can you tell me how they're being
scored like what is the algorithm and
she said well I asked my contact at the
Department of Education and they told me
don't you wouldn't understand it it's
math and I was like well that's not good
enough
like as a mathematician let me just say
that mathematics is supposed to clarify
not not confuse right so that's not
that's not a thing you do with math
that's weaponizing math right not okay
and so I asked her to keep pushing that
she got through three different layers
each layer of saying to her you wouldn't
understand its back three times then she
finally got this white paper which was
unreadable to me and I'd been like I got
a PhD math have been doing modeling for
like seven years and I cannot understand
what his white paper said so what I did
was I filed for a Freedom of Information
Act request to get the source code for
the algorithm and it was denied
and by the way I should say that the
reason I thought of that is because the
New York Post had kept and filed a
Freedom of Information Act request and
gotten successfully gotten all the
teachers scores and all the teachers
names and scores and they published it
as an act of public shaming for the
teachers really awful right but I was
like well if they can get the scores I
actually have to get the way the scores
are made right makes sense I was denied
and then I contacted someone at the
Institute that the data Institute that
built this score through a friend of a
friend and they explained to me that I
would never get that source code because
they had a contract with the city of New
York which stipulated that no one in New
York City would get that sorta wouldn't
ever see how this stuff was made it was
secret from there
which is to say secret from the
officials in the Department of Education
so they can't explain to their teachers
how they're being scored so part of this
book I mean really the book as a whole
as a manifesto of your argument about
how wet math is being weaponized here as
I thought maybe you could give us an
overview of how you came to that place
because you were building these for
finance for a while and and then
kind of became the enemy of Finance as
my words not yours right but I mean
joining Occupy Wall Street is probably
not something your hedge fund would have
smiled upon right definitely yeah
does the quick tour through those many
years of your life yeah yeah so I joined
occupy in mm of it I started back up I
joined my hedge fund in the early 2007
and like rights headed straight into the
crisis you know like walked in and that
boom crisis and I was like really
disillusioned very quickly because the
people that I thought were experts
really didn't seem to know much about
what was going on it didn't really seem
to understand the market which is to say
that I understood it perfectly but they
didn't seem to understand it that much
better than I did at the heart of it and
by the way the person introduced us
talked about Rubik's cubes like that's
why I fell in love math is Rubik's cubes
like how beautiful our Rubik's cubes
like I had this idea of mathematics
being this pure clean and beautiful kind
of almost artistic endeavor right and
then and then abet go back to the
financial crisis like at the heart of
the financial crisis was this
mathematical lie so the opposite of the
beauty of a Rubik's Cube the triple-a
ratings on mortgage-backed securities
which you know you might not think of
them as mathematics but they are they
were like they they were promises that
people who were really good at math with
PhDs were in the back like crunching the
numbers and promising that these
mortgages weren't going to go bad well
they weren't doing that they were just
they were basically creating a lie and
selling it for money and the triple-a
ratings not only difficult people
believe it but they people believed it
so much that the the scale
market for mortgage-backed securities
was very very large was one of the
reasons it was such a big deal so anyway
that's one of the things that I realized
was that again it was a weaponization of
people's trust in mathematics like
people trusted math they trust about
petitions and it and I shouldn't say
math itself wasn't the problem it was
that people were were basically corrupt
and they are shielding themselves and
shielding their corruption from from
people's prying eyes by calling it math
and saying like don't look here you
would understand that it's math and it's
trust right anyway and it's right just
you have to trust us
so that's kind of the big thing that I
realized it should have like this isn't
the right way to deal with math and then
I left I left blood finance and became a
data scientist and then I was like okay
well doing almost the same thing in data
science since I was in finance instead
of instead of predicting markets I'm
predicting people that's what data
scientists do they just use historical
data to build algorithms to predict
people and if you're predicting
personality traits and that didn't seem
so bad but until I came across the sort
of the teacher value item all I just
mentioned which I was like that's not
good and then I think the the moment
that I decided to put my job at write
this book was caused by this one
interaction that I had at my startup
where this venture capitalist came to
visit and he was thinking of he was
thinking of investing in our company
what a Series B funding round and so we
all sat and listened to him talk about
the future of tailored advertising which
is what I was working on I was working
at advertising in the space of travel
like on Expedia or something which I did
that was relatively benign like what do
you do when you do that kind of thing
you offer some people like hotel rooms
and some people you don't offer the
hotel room so you're giving
opportunities to some people and you're
not giving them opportunities to others
it's like a very kind of mild way
of segregating society that makes sense
you guys deserve these offers you guys
don't deserve these offers um
that's I didn't think of it as
particularly evil I still don't think it
was particularly evil but then this
guy's so gave us this idea of what his
future dream for the world of the
internet was and he was like I have this
dream that like some day it didn't sound
like Martin Luther King let me take that
he's like I've had this idea this like
this is what I hope to see in tailored
advertising he said I hope to see
something that I get offered trips to
Aruba and jet skis and I never again
have to see another University of
Phoenix ad because those are for people
like me and everyone around me laughed
and I was like what what you know I
thought that whatever happened to the
democratizing force of the internet you
know like this is this is the goal of
the people constructing the modern
Internet which is to segregate people
and silo them by class so that we can we
the technologists the people who are
lucky who are getting scored well scored
high we have opportunities we have like
toys and and things that we like to play
with and then people on the other side
of the spectrum can be preyed upon well
as I make money off you from your
vacations and I make money off them from
exploitative universities that give
worthless degrees right just where
make money off of them and if you're in
a certain class I can make money off
them by exploiting them right and if you
think about the way the tailored
advertising works like there's an
auction for the eyes of whomever you're
talking about and it's very efficient
because there's all sorts of
demographics known about the person that
you're about to put it out in front of
and you know again if you're talking
about someone like me I they're very
good at finding me and showing me yarn
because I'm I'm like very vulnerable to
alpaca I mean like they know my number
right and that's okay because like I
love the yard and sometimes I'm like oh
yeah I want that yard you know but at
the other end again like for some people
the most the most profitable thing is to
get that person to take out a federal
loan which goes straight to a for-profit
college Saddles them with that and does
not give them an actual education and
we've seen some for-profit colleges
being closed down recently which is
great news but it wasn't it was an
enormous and it still is a relatively
large industry but at the time the
venture capitalists came and talked to
my company I had never seen it
University of Phoenix at I didn't even
know what it was
honestly it was in 2012 I think I looked
it up and it's I saw that Apollo group
which is the parent company of
University of Phoenix was the single
biggest Google ads buyer that quarter so
that's what I realized like I am NOT
going to see the failure of this this
kind of algorithm everyone here saw the
failure of the triple-a ratings on
mortgages everyone in the world saw that
because it was so loud when it exploded
but who is gonna see the failure of this
kind of this kind of algorithm
because we have segregated ourselves
online to such an extent that when I
would somebody falls prey to that kind
of trap we do not see it in fact we
blame them for it how we do it on time
because I can keep going okay great
where do I jump in here okay I've got
like ten questions I'm gonna smush them
all into one okay so you know one of the
things you talk about in your book is
like potentially we have people who are
building these algorithms take something
equivalent to a Hippocratic oath and you
know certainly they're I mean there's no
ethics training for people like us I
mean I didn't you don't even like it
makes people uncomfortable in computer
science departments to talk about ethics
I think you know and so there's training
is a good part but I think the question
I came away with is if there's money to
be made by exploiting people it seems
like that's gonna happen and we saw it
with the mortgage-backed securities but
we saw it with Enron right like back in
2001 you see these phone calls from
Enron traders who remember back then you
know shut down the power grid in
California just to make money on energy
futures and they're talking about the
old people who are getting screwed
basically because they have to pay these
enormous rates for their electricity it
seems like the market is set up where if
we can use these algorithms if we can
use anything that is vaguely within the
rules to exploit people to make money
we'll do it and I wonder what your
thoughts are on how we change that part
of the system
right so I'm not expecting all
corruption to end right um
period right but I do I do want one
particular form of corruption to be
challenged and that is the corruption
where people claim that because it's an
algorithm it is beyond morals every
algorithm has embedded values in it it's
just that we the people who create the
algorithms and who deploy them and who
own them are the ones that get to decide
what those morals are so we need to
start challenging that right and when I
there's a very very I have a very
specific reason to define the algorithms
like I do the weapons of mass
destruction because it I perform triage
this is my the service I've done for the
world as I performed triage on the space
of all algorithms
I've told us where to focus our
attention and for those algorithms many
of them are accident accidentally
terrible algorithms some of them are
just they're out there terrible because
people who are greedy will will always
want to do that so so I do I do think
that for the algorithms that that rise
to the level or or maybe go down to the
level of something that is potentially a
weapon of mass destruction we need to
have more scrutiny there may need to be
laws about that because a lot of this
stuff as you mentioned there will be no
free market solution to this the free
market will not solve this problem it
actually makes money its profitable to
be discriminatory so you can't ask
someone please stop being discriminatory
because it's not great for society even
though you make more money doing it
that's just not going to happen that's
why we have laws around things like fair
lending we have the Fair Credit
Reporting Act we have Equal Credit
Opportunity Act
these are anti-discrimination laws that
were written in that night
70s that essentially regulated things
like FICO scores and they're not perfect
but there are hell of a lot better than
what we have for what's going on a big
data so I'm basically arguing that
number one the public as a whole stops
stopped trusting algorithms pushback
demand accountability because when you
have secrecy you have no accountability
so especially when you're you're being
assessed at your job you should be able
to know how that is what's happening
like what how am I being assessed
exactly you should be able to ask that
question but there also have to be rules
and regulations around things that rise
to the level of widespread and impactful
and I think just to kind of close this
out a point that you make very clearly
in the book which is one that I've been
thinking a lot about in another domain
is that if you have an algorithm that
seems unfair or seems like it should
work differently then that's because of
a human basically right if you have an
algorithm that's discriminating and it
doesn't consider race but it does
consider zip code that's because whoever
programmed it didn't think that using
zip code didn't consider that that could
discriminate based on race and if you
have you know a chatbot that starts
viewings Holocaust denial and Nazi stuff
it's because whoever programmed it
didn't think that maybe we need to think
about minorities and women because they
get harassed online all the time and you
know if you have an industry that's made
up of people who are greedy or who are
ignorant of the problems of people not
in my class they can be ignorant of the
sorts of problems that their algorithms
create and I think this this
accountability issue that you raise also
gets to us as algorithmic developers
that we need to think about these
problems we need to know about them and
not just know about optimizing the
profit or optimizing the output as well
so I just want to add one last vantage
that there's been a lot of recent
publicized examples of like spectacular
failures of algorithms coming from like
the Twitter bot and the Facebook
algorithm so that's that's what we get
to see guys like most of the most of the
shitty algorithms out there that are
like ruining people's lives are never
seen by the
public their business to business
dealings like the one that was the
personality test for the four Kroger's
supermarket so it's just if we think
that things that if things that are
known to be under public scrutiny are
that bad just imagine like what's going
on when there is no public that can
scrutinize these things so I think
you're taking my mic now right okay
Thank You Jen
[Applause]
see a few hands we'll start in the back
thanks very much this is incredibly
interesting talking about the algorithm
as as a as a device for controlling sort
of for establishing or maintaining a
control system and the algorithm is this
device that none of us really
understands so it's presented as valid
it reminds me of other things that we
have in society that accomplish the same
function like perhaps constitutional law
or things that no one really understands
but they're legitimizing a structure
that probably we ought to be get to that
getting the bottom of these other things
have usually a like a priestly class
that sort of is the only people who
understand though you guys come from
this in algorithms
what is this class and what are they
thinking about this and are you a
renegade from this class or you know is
everybody thinking about this what
what's the deal because I don't know any
of these people really intended thank
you yes it is a priestly class and much
to my shame a lot of the people who are
in this class would they prefer it that
way
well it needs like actually pretty
flattering to be told that you're but
magical because you're a mathematician
right not enough of us are worried about
our impact on larger society but I do
want to say that when I started this
this project four years ago I quit my
job to write this book I was really
panicking because I didn't see anyone
around me he was worried about this but
now four years later I have an entire
community of people including computer
scientists sociologists anthropologists
technical technologists that are all
super concerned with this stuff and in
particular I've been hanging out with
some people who like me are interested
in develop
tools and auditing tools specifically to
like audit the black box to look into
the black box in some sense and I don't
want to make that mysterious so like
what I mean by that is you know if you
give a sociological experiment we're
kind of borrowing from sociology like if
it if sociologists wanted to see whether
a hiring practice was racist they would
send like to like a bunch of
applications and with reasonable quote
like similar qualifications and had like
black names and white names and see if
like the white names get more callback
for interview like you can do that with
an algorithm to you can do similar
things with an algorithm it's crude and
it's like it would be the first
generation of auditing tools for
algorithms but it's exactly the kind of
thing that we need to start doing so
long way long story long we do have we
have work to do in our priestly class of
technologists who work with data but we
do have a growing a growing group of
people who wanted who want to think
about this and by the way it's also like
a field that should be developed right
like I feel like in 20 years they'll be
conferences about this kind of thing
right now there's nothing as far as I
know there's not even a journal but
that's interested in in publishing
things like this but there will be and
by the way one last thing is I would
start I would say that at the beginning
of this this field has already taken
root in data journalism if you look at
like Pro Publica their recent work with
auditing one of the recidivism risk
models we didn't even talk about
recidivism risk models but it's these
risk models that judge is used to
sentence people to jail and it's you
know reason to believe it's racist and
one of the week one of the reporting
teams at Pro Publica
actually found a bunch of data using
FOIA requests an auditor and
it to be racist so there's work being
done here but it's but it's in early
stages
thank you this is wonderful I'm a
physician I was a little bit late but I
want to suggest two areas in which this
might have something to do with medicine
there's tremendous confidence in the
medical community could you speak up I'm
sorry I'm sorry there we go I'm a
physician the data comes up in two ways
the first is that the medical community
and the business community are convinced
that all the data go into the electronic
medical record is going to give us brand
new insights into taking care of people
and health and I wonder and it's not
your field but I wonder what you think
of this I'm skeptical
the second thing is the other another
big push in medicine is to force
individual physicians to take risk for
the patients that they take care of that
is to say if the patient doesn't require
so much care you do well if the patient
requires more care than you anticipate
you're screwed and we're not insurance
companies I wonder if there are
algorithms that will be developed so
that physicians and insurance companies
even though everything is supposed to be
on the up-and-up and you don't do
pre-existing conditions
we'll use information that's publicly
available or reasonably publicly
available to figure out who's a risk and
who's not great questions
um I'm not an expert in your field as
you said but I do want to say that you
know I worry as well as you do about
about all the hype around how much data
can improve medical the medical field
and so I would I would focus as a non
data person you know and I would focus
even though I am a data person if I were
you on like on accountability and
explicable testing procedures for this
thing like the problem let me let me
explain with respect by an allergy the
problem with the teacher stuff I I said
before but I'll say it again is that
there's no ground truth like compared to
what how do we know this is any good
like how correlated is it to the thing
that we know is good like it's it's so
bad right do you have to actually demand
the kind of accountability that would
make you trust it if Martians came down
from Mars and said I have a way of
fixing medicine and you're like well I
don't trust you so convinced me like
this has to be convincing in a in a real
in a real way and right now we just
people just say big data and they just
throw it out there like it's already
convincing but you as a doctor need to
also be convinced you need to you need
to be see shown why it's really good how
it it agrees with you in the ways that
you absolutely know are true and
therefore you start trusting it in ways
that you're not quite sure yourself
having said that I did an example of
half
testing so there's an example I wanted
to throw out there which is that an
algorithm just imagine that we had
really good Big Data algorithms for
medicine even if we did have that and it
was really good like we could predict
future
illnesses well that's not necessarily a
good thing and that's one of the things
that people get wrong when they talk
about precision medicine or all this
stuff which is that like in the hands of
your doctor trying to help you stay stay
well it is probably a good thing if it
it was done well and that's a big if but
in the hands of an insurance company who
can charge you more for future illnesses
that's a terrible thing right and it's
something that weighs not addressed by
Obamacare Obamacare addresses like
pre-existing conditions not future
conditions right and finally imagine
that was in the hands of Walmart and I'm
not saying it is but like a large
employer who gets to choose who to hire
and who not to hire based on their
future insurance costs that would be
really bad so I'm just saying like
there's no there's no guarantee even if
an algorithm is accurate that is going
to be used for good
I just wanted to chime in on the end of
that because I'm kind of in this space
building those algorithms and and they
kind of terrify me hope so what we were
talking before we just published a paper
where we're looking at people who are
starting treatment in AAA they're going
to a first Alcoholics Anonymous meeting
we analyzed their Twitter profiles from
before they start going to AAA and can
predict with about 85 or 90% accuracy if
they're going to stay sober and have a
lot of colleagues working on this
there's one group that looked at women
and their Twitter accounts over the
course of their pregnancy and on the day
they gave birth could predict with about
eighty-five percent accuracy if they'll
develop postpartum depression or not
great for your doctor right if you can
go to your OBGYN and she can push a
button and say all right we need to
monitor you for this that's great but
for all the cases that you mentioned
that's really
scary and there's work in this community
that I'm involved in looking at also
things like diabetes obesity heart
disease as well as sight conditions like
depression PTSD which we're getting very
good at and you know in one hand the
science is really interesting that we
can do this on the other hand the
implications in the fact that there's no
regulation over how you can use the
output of these algorithms and no one
can't even know if you're doing it I
think is really terrifying and you know
I spend a lot of my time going around
talking to big companies saying you need
to be careful about this because bad
things are gonna happen so I think it's
a really scary space at this point
especially being down there you know
building and looking at these algorithms
I'm a very dystopian view okay we're all
terrified right I didn't even know that
you could do that with Twitter that's
just that's awful
so talking about the medical profession
reminds me of HIPAA and of HIPPA and so
in relation to the Kroger vocational
testing thing why isn't that kind of
information as sensitive and hence as
worthy of being protected by a law like
the HIPAA law as the medical information
that is protected thank you for saying
that sir that's one of the things I call
for in my book but anything better if
you had read the book and you're just
like oh I thought you were okay no I
also don't have the perfect algorithm
I'm picking everyone so hands in the
audience so bear with me but try to
scatter eyes yes our name is Jamal Abdul
Alim I'm a reporter with diverse issues
in higher education one of the things I
was hoping you could address was some of
the potential benefits of in the cases
that you cited for instance with the
teacher example it seems as though it
was just the use of the information or
maybe of wrong analysis but it seems
like it actually helped identify an
instance of cheating and in education so
I wonder what you would say to that that
is it's not really the algorithm but
it's just a way that the that that
they're used along similar lines what do
you say to businesses in the second
example that you cited in terms of using
personality tests that for them it's a
matter of efficiency and that it's a
matter of saving time on the front end
of the hiring process
I'm sure you've anticipated that I'm
just curious as to what your response is
to that thank you
Thanks so it with respect to the teacher
value-added model the only reason there
was cheating in the first place because
it was because the the structure of the
value-added model and
self was had too many incentives so it
basically when you have enough
incentives in place and high pressures
and high stakes that it causes cheating
so I don't think it makes sense it's
circular reasoning to say that it oh
that one the good thing had happened
from this regime was that a detected
cheating I'm not an education expert so
I don't actually have a solution for
education but I just the thing I wanted
to point out with that model is this
like the most it's kind of the lowest
bar of all my examples because it's just
a bad model statistically speaking now
I'll tell you my evidence for this
besides idiosyncratic information like
some people were getting scored for four
classes they didn't even teach and it
was like a computer error all sorts of
crazy stories like that but there's also
this I told you guys that the New York
Post shamed all those teachers so there
was this high school math teacher Gary
Rubinstein at Stuyvesant High School in
New York City who did something really
clever again I couldn't get the access
to the source code right so I couldn't
actually look at this model but what he
did was he found teachers that had two
scores because it may be taught 7th
grade math and 8th grade math so they
have two different scores and you would
expect since this was supposed to be an
overall score for as a teacher that
those would be consistent right if
you've got a 78 for the 7th grade math
you can expect maybe an 82 for 8th grade
math something like that well he plotted
that and he found uniform distribution
which is to say practically as likely to
get a 90 comma zero as to get a 40 comma
40 like it was just all over the map
there was no in other words almost a
random number generator so there's no
reason to think this is informational
now what I say almost every remembering
around 24% correlation which is very low
which is to say you couldn't possibly
take a given teacher and say this is
your fault you are a bad teacher because
you got a low score
can't do that it's not strong enough
evidence but it's not a zero percent
correlation maybe at some kind of
district level you could glean a useful
information but again I just want to
throw in you would only be able to glean
in useful information about test scores
right test scores are already
fundamentally probably not enough
information to understand whether
students have good teachers so anyway
again like not an education expert but
I'm just like I don't think so now in
terms of the hiring practices my
complaint with the Kyle beams
personality test is that it was illegal
and secret right assuming that we have
we'd get evidence eventually that it is
essentially a mental health assessment
which we think it is we have evidence
too for that
so like assuming that's true which again
we can't figure out directly because
it's secret but assuming that's true
like the problem there is that it's
illegal like it's against the law
there's lots of laws around hiring like
you have to be you can't discriminate
when you hire in all sorts of ways I
don't actually have a problem with using
big data to help you filter resumes but
they have it has to be legal at the very
least and they should be transparent as
well so that people understand what
they're being tested for
you think a very challenging picture in
a frightening picture you paint a very
frightening picture of the misuse of
algorithms and and that sort of thing
the average Facebook user has no idea
what an algorithm is and those people
who were most affected by the failure of
the housing crisis still don't know that
any algorithm had anything to do with it
at all
how do we get this information out aside
from buying your book
it's very everybody that's important I
think because most people still don't
have any idea of the impact of
algorithms on their lives yeah I mean
that's why I wrote the book like I feel
like people don't really understand like
most people at least as of like 2012 so
when the survey was done didn't realize
that Facebook had an algorithm so
they're not even aware of the algorithm
I think that's starting to fade I think
but with the whole discussion around the
trending news stories people are
starting to see that they're not seeing
everything that you know and some some
subpopulations have like done tricky
things where they figure out how to get
there how to get their friends to see
their posts because you if you just post
something your friends might not
necessarily see it but I heard about
this teenage population that puts brand
names into the post like Coke and then
it gets pushed up in the ranking so your
friends get to see it which is funny
yeah I mean that's like a public like a
long term public the goal so first make
people aware of the algorithm and second
make them skeptical
[Music]
so one one interesting point on this
because this is something I spend a lot
of time looking at is that if you look
at surveys from like the few studies of
the Internet in the American life which
is a great representative study
awareness of the algorithms but also
concern about the impact is very clearly
correlated with socioeconomic status and
also race so people who are poorer are
less worried about these algorithms and
also less aware of them which if you're
talking about being exploited by these
algorithms the people who are most
likely to be exploited but I'm not going
to be exploited that much but the people
who are most likely to be exploited are
also less worried and less aware and so
it's kind of this cycle where you know
well there's not really anything to
worry about nothing Bad's gonna happen
except you're actually the target so
that makes it even more complicated so
their studies would be an interesting
thing to look at for the data but of
course it doesn't solve the problem I
think you know your book is a great way
to start getting this out there you know
I like to go around and talk about it
but I think we just need this massive
education campaign because these
algorithms are so powerful and so
impactful on our lives that it's kind of
a basic kind of literacy that we all
need to start developing to at least
know that they're there even if we don't
get to know all the details of how they
work I'll just add one more thing which
is like it's not enough it's not enough
to say everyone should be aware and
everyone should protect themselves
because of exactly what Jen just said
like the reason I wrote this book is
because I saw this like time and time
again as a class issue this is these are
tools of social control and the people
who are at the top are controlling the
people at the bottom and it's not enough
to say you should have been aware of the
possible exploitation I would have done
to you like that's why we actually need
rules about this it's not just like for
everyone for themselves that's not good
enough
so all right hi miss karaoke yeah you're
like I'm a data scientist and a big fan
of your blog and I work in health care
payment and and I work in a healthcare
payment and so a lot of our data
modeling is using these algorithms to
determine things like payment which
relates to who are you are talking about
but I guess my question is as building
on your point that it's okay to be using
these algorithms for things like hiring
practices or for making some sort of
large-scale decision where big data
would help but I was wondering I don't
know if this is probably covered in your
book for like what you think a good
solution is in terms of the algorithms
themselves like what is the correction
mechanism here for dealing with this
inequity that arises in application
because they're sort of like a way that
data scientists or developers can be
thinking about these like inequitable
implications or these like welfare like
effects when they're building these
algorithms from the ground up thank you
yeah thank you so the thing about the
thing about the promise of big data is
that it hasn't been fulfilled yet but it
still exists the promise of big data is
that we can make things more fair and I
think we can I mean I'm not holding my
breath but I think we can do that and
part of it is the realization that just
because it's an algorithm is it's all
right we're not done part of that is
developing tools to audit to see whether
it is currently fair part of that is
developing tools to say how do we fix
there's a growth it's not fair how do we
make it fair that it's kind of like the
good news is that when you let's compare
let's compare a company that has like
discriminatory practices for hiring with
an algorithm that has discriminatory
practices for hiring the problem with
the company is that if you interview
people and ask them how they choose to
hire they will lie to you or they maybe
that maybe they actually don't realize
that they're being discriminatory
because people don't realize their own
that's right whereas an algorithm will
not lie so you can check that and then
once you actually have a successful
algorithm that's good but you have to
you have to have this like sufficient
trust in the algorithm and sufficient
auditing to be able to to know that it's
actually doing a good job Mike can you
hear me oh okay good so my partner and I
did a fair amount of work on Bernie's
campaign earlier this year and we
experienced a lot of exasperation and
frustration at the fact that Bernie's
campaign and I'm sure the other
Democratic campaigns use data from a
company called van and what we were
finding is that the data was sending us
in terms of canvassing to a lot of
neighborhoods that in our opinion did
not match up with the demographics that
we know we knew to be Bernie supporters
so four on our end it felt frustrating
that the data didn't seem to be working
for us and that our higher-ups didn't
see that just because there was data in
a certain demographic didn't mean that
that was the best demographic to target
but beyond that on a broader scale I'm a
bit concerned about the fact that it
seemed to be contacting a certain type
of voter and not another type of voter
we seem to be going to a lot of wealthy
neighborhoods and not a lot of like less
affluent neighborhoods and so certain
sorts of people are being reminded to
vote while others aren't so first I
wanted to ask if you've looked at all at
van and if you hadn't please ask you
like to look at van and in terms of if
there's a place where I think that this
algorithm just the existence of it is
probably actually not the best thing for
society I don't think that there should
be a private company that owns the data
on voters and lends it out to campaigns
what can we do about that like where is
the power struggle here like behind that
great question
yeah so I have a chapter on politics and
and you know my sub the subtitle of my
book is how big data increases
inequality and threatens democracy and
this is the kind of the part of the
second part right threatens democracy
actually I think I think just having
exacerbated inequality at some point is
a threat to democracy because some
people have such confusing and badly
scheduled lives that they don't have
time to be civically engaged but putting
that aside the threat to democracy that
I see coming from big data is is the my
clinical micro-targeting stuff and the
way it is uneven so I don't have time to
go into it a lot but I think you're
absolutely right that it's targeting
only special people and those special
people typically are either people that
could be counted on for donating a lot
of money so they have bigger voices or
people that live in swing states and are
swing voters which is a very small
sliver of us all as you as you know it
also is a surveys these weird feedback
loops where they don't spend money on
people that they think will definitely
vote or definitely think will not vote
they only spend money essentially on
people that nay vote but having said
that if if somebody who is supposed to
vote doesn't vote that gets corrected
they will spend money on that person the
next time around but if somebody who
doesn't vote doesn't vote favor they're
continually ignored so that means that
like this sort of it's a very
socio-economic cleaving in terms of
voting but the larger issue is this the
larger issue of politics and data is
this what is efficient for campaigns is
inefficient for democracy what is
efficient for campaigns is to is to know
everybody here profile use perfectly and
send you the message that the campaign
wants you to hear that's not what is
good for us as a group what's good for
us as a group
is a broad public discussion of how the
candidates stand on the various issues
but that's not what's happening with
political micro-targeting so if if I if
Rand Paul targeted me he would find the
thing that I agree with him on which is
breaking up the big banks and then if I
went to his web page to see what he
thinks about other stuff he would follow
me with a cookie and say oh she's the
one who we wanted who was afraid of the
big banks let's show her that like
they're controlling the information I
have about them that's not democratic we
want we want information about
candidates to be utterly open and we
want to have more information about them
than they have about us and that's not
what's happening I'm gonna play these
let me freak you out more role but so
anywho people are gonna vote for
something we're pretty good at we in the
last election we had like 97% accuracy
and guessing new people before but
here's the scary part Thanks
if you remember in the last election
they had a little thing that some of you
probably saw that says hey here's all
your friends who have voted or 20% of
Thanks
something like they could get half a
percent more people to vote if they
showed that than if they didn't so
imagine they want to get dumped they
find all the people who they think will
vote for Donald Trump and then they show
them the thing that gets more people to
vote but they don't show that to the
people who will vote for somebody else
right then suddenly they're having a
really significant impact on the
election itself I don't think they have
any aspirations that seems relatively
apolitical and these sorts of things
you're giving me a skeptical look but
I'll say I'm not calling facebook out
specifically but the fact is the
companies that control what you see with
these algorithms have the option to have
real impacts on elections by
understanding who gets to see stuff
that's going to make you go vote and
hiding that from people who don't and we
haven't seen evidence of that happening
yet but that's a real possibility with
the technology we have today and I think
one of the most concerning things in
this political space yeah I'll reiterate
that the only reason I look skeptical is
because the population of people on
Facebook is already not bipartisan right
there's more Democrat voters than
Republican voters so if they showed
everyone that would be their fair right
I'm showing this to everyone if they
showed it to everyone it would have more
impact on the Democratic election we
have time for one more question
so
honey so I work for an online advertiser
that specializes in running ads on
political websites and something that's
happened over the course of the last
year is that a lot of major advertisers
have gotten really skittish about
running ads on right wing websites as
the American political right live
increasingly radicalizes this is sort of
half noble intentions and half sort of
being able to save face publicly a
saying like oh don't worry n-double-a-cp
we don't sell t-shirts to people to read
right Bart for example but something
that's happening is that whenever we
pull out of a market we always look to
see who comes and replaces of us and in
this particular case basically everybody
who is replacing us our online
advertisers who sell weapons or videos
about how Hillary Clinton you know has a
video that if you see if any American
sees will guarantee she's not elected
and this is you know part of like the
really intense is this ideological
segregation that's happening on the
Internet is because mainstream
advertisers are pulling out of right
wing websites they're just sort of the
feedback loop is steadily increasing for
them because even their ads are getting
really biased and in my opinion I'm
getting I think that it was better when
the mainstream like Google was selling
them you know cars as opposed to I you
know crazy people selling them like
really big knives and this is something
that is done through algorithms because
for ever you know the great wing website
you know about Breitbart you know there
are hundreds of thousands of elements
you don't if you discover through
algorithms and stitch tasking account
managers hey are we selling advertising
to racists we're going to comment on
this phenomenon
I mean it's it's it's I think larger
than my book right it's and I don't know
how to address it the like the growing
partisan divide in our country it's it's
not
I don't think singularly due to
algorithms and I agree that like the
face the way we live in siloed spaces on
Facebook and talk to each other and the
echo chambers is part of it but is that
also not the only part but and I also
don't know how to but I agree it's a
problem we'll agree on that all right
well think thank you so much Kathy for
coming out thank you Jim for joining us
then thank everyone else for coming out
I think it's been a great talk and a
great conversation like like I said
we're gonna have the books available for
purchase in the bookstore and Kathy will
be here signing after so thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]